His computer generated voice has become
familiar to generations of people
instantly garnering recognition
as the words of a genius.
His name is answered in the same breath
as Einstein and Galileo and he had a few
people can understand the
complexities of his theories.
What they do know though is that Stephen
Hawking overcame physical obstacles
that would have defeated many people
and he did that in order to pursue his
passions.
In the process,
he became an inspiration to millions and
added greatly to our understanding of
the universe.
In this week's biographics,
we undertake a brief history of Stephen
Hawking and just before we get started
with the video to that,
do you want to say it but it's brought
to you by the great courses plus the
great courses plus is an on demand video
learning service has got lectures from
top Ivy League professors as well as
experts from other places like the
Smithsonian National Geographic excetera.
It's like a university education, but
at your own pace. There are no tests,
no schedules,
and it's incredibly easy to access.
You can do it on the PC or a tablet on
a phone and you can get a free trial by
going to the great courses plus.com
forward slash biographics and more about
vast.
A little later in this video,
Steven William Hawking was born at the
height of the Second World War on January
the eighth 1842 in Oxford,
England.
It was exactly 300 years after the
death of the father of astronomy.
Galileo Galilei. Both of his parents
were graduates of Oxford University.
There's father frank was
a medical researcher while
his mother Isabel worked as
a medical research secretary.
They were a middle class family with
both parents being thought of in their
community as rather old brain boxes.
Steven began his schooling at
Byron. How School? Then high gate,
the school used a new progressive method
of teaching to which Steven did not
take.
He stayed here for three years though and
by the age of eight he could still not
read at the war's end.
Frank was offered a job at the National
Institute of Medical Research and the
family moved to St Albans.
Yeah.
Frank wanted his son to attend
the prestigious Westminster
School. How are the,
Steven was sick on the day of the entrance
exam and he ended up going to nearby
St Albans school instead.
Steven at this school he
was seen as a nerdy outcast.
He was small and skinny and he spoke
with a list but that made it hard to
understand what he was saying.
For the first two years of his time there,
he was very much a loner.
In the third year,
he managed to find a small group of
like minded friends that are extra
curricular activities included going on
long bike rides and didn't venting board
games.
Steven,
he proved to be the most inventive and
creative of this group and we'd come up
with the rules and organize the
state of play in these games.
Steven has two younger sisters and a
brother who was adopted in 1955 however it
is. Parents showed little interest
in domestic affairs. The walking,
the house was filled with books and
the parents were too busy feeding their
minds.
Often reading books during dinner rather
than conversing with their children.
Steven regularly had his friends over
where they would busy themselves building
model planes and electronic devices.
From about the age of 12 onwards,
that discussions extended
from science to religion.
They debated the big questions of life
among themselves and it was at this time
that Steven began forming his
atheistic beliefs. Stephen's teachers,
they soon identified a remarkable talent
for mathematics and physics in him.
He seems to intuitively know the answers
without having to work through the
problem. By the age of 14 he knew that
he wanted to specialize in physics.
He felt that he could provide an insight
into the big questions that he and his
friends had been grappling with.
Where are we in a row from why we
are here and where we're going?
At the age of 17 Stephen felt ready to
take the entrance exam for university
college at Oxford.
The exam was extremely challenging
consisting of five papers and the general
knowledge exam.
Walking came out with a
score of 95% once again,
the he found himself as an outsider
at this prestigious place of learning.
He had no friends and so he
kept to himself. Furthermore,
he found the lectures to be too
basic for him, which they boredom.
He stopped going to many of them
and still easily pastors exams.
The only lectures that he got any
intellectual challenge from where those
presented by his physics tutor,
Robert Berman Hawking was well ahead of
his fellow students despite being much
younger than many of them.
His knowledge was so advanced that he
occasionally made corrections in the very
textbooks that he was studying.
At the end of his second year,
he easily won the university
physics prize. Well, as Oxford,
Stephen took up the sport of rowing.
Rowing was and still is,
a very serious business
at Oxford University and
Steven threw himself into it
with complete commencements.
He became a coxswain.
The person who yells
instructions to the rowers.
He simply loved the thrill of going,
doing his team to success.
It was as involvement in the rowing team,
which allowed Stevens a breakout of
his isolation and develop some budding
friendships.
By the time that his old schoolmates
from since albums turn diapers freshmen.
They were surprised to discover that
the awkward Biver they knew had become a
confident young man who had found a
comfortable niche for himself at Oxford.
In fact,
he became so immersed in the social life
of his environment and that despite his
innate ability,
he began to fall back academically
with his third year exams approaching.
He quickly realized that
he was not fully prepared.
He decided that his best about where's
to focus solely on the theoretical
problems that he could solve
using his innate skill.
The results of the exam had em teetering
between a first and second class honors
degree.
He needed it to be first class in order
to gain admittance to Cambridge where
any plans to begin his work on his phd.
The result depended on a final oral exam,
which she haste gaining fest costs on
us before heading off to Cambridge,
Hawking's took a trip to
Iran with the friends.
He began Cambridge in October of 1962
while he had been expecting to work
directly under the guidance
of the famous astronomer Fred.
How this was actually not to be the case.
He was disappointed to find out that
it's tuna was actually Dennis Schema.
The reality of the situation was the,
the organ was actually better off on
the ski mom who had more time to go to
students than Hoyle would have had
hawking specialized in the study of
cosmology. There was, now that he faced
his first real intellectual challenge,
he quickly realized that his mathematical
knowledge was not deep enough for him
to really get to grips
with the complications of
Einstein's general theory of
relativity.
At about this time, hawking began to
experience some physical abnormalities.
His speech was starting to slur and he
was prone to losing his balance when he
returns home for the
1962 Christmas holidays.
His parents were so concerned that
they sent him to a specialist.
A series of tests were undertaken and
then it was simply a matter of waiting for
the results.
In the meantime,
hawking attended in New Year's Eve party
where he met a young lady by the name
of Jane Wilde. Jane who was
attracted to the eccentric? Yeah,
intellectual and the two struck
up an immediate attraction.
Steven had already returned to Cambridge
when the results of the test came
through. He had developed a als which
is also known as Lou Gehrig's disease.
It's a condition in which the body's
cells to generate causing paralysis and
muscle atrophy. Yes. While
the body deteriorates,
the brain is unaffected,
so hawking now at the prospect of being
trapped within a dysfunctional body.
The prognosis related to hawking was
that he had just two years to live.
The symptoms that he experienced and
the first few months were weakness.
Stammering while speaking and
having trouble swallowing.
Hawking later reflected on
his feelings at the time,
a disease which can never be hills.
I'm in the clutches of the disease
which is calling me closer to my death.
The thought itself used to bring
cramps or fear in the stomach.
Why have I only then
caught by Jess disease?
Stephen's doctors and his parents
advised him to continue his studies at
Cambridge.
They believe that staying focused on
the goal of achieving his phd would help
him to cope with the pain and frustration
of dealing with this failing body,
but Hawkings struggled with the idea
that he was working so hard for a reward
that he would probably
not live to receive.
What was the points is the question that
kept dancing around in the back of his
brain.
It has been reported that hawking fell
into a deep depression at this time.
He was spending his days drinking and
listening to Wagner and a student flats.
However, the man himself actually
later denied this a session.
He certainly went into a period
of confusion and lack of focus,
but he also did his best to continue
with the studies. After a year,
his symptoms had stabilized and
his spirits began to pick up.
It was also this time that he picked
up his relationship with Jane Wilde.
He became a great supporter
and encourager of him.
It was she who gave him a glimmer
of hope for a brighter future.
The two became engaged in October of 1964
Jane had committed herself to looking
after Steven for the rest of his life,
and they were married on July the 14th
1965 after two years of living with the
disease,
hawking was able to get around on a cane.
Though this speech was becoming
increasingly unintelligible,
he was still searching for an area
of focus for his thesis. Fred Hoyle,
who is just pronounced his theories
on the discovery of the universe,
and hawking believed the
coils theory was flawed,
and he publicly challenged these theories.
He then proceeded to write
his thesis on the topic,
and it was well received
by the cosmology community.
It was this that really established
talking as a player of note in the field
after graduating from Cambridge with
a phd in Applied Mathematics and
theoretical physics applied
for and received a fellowship.
It's Cambridge is gone,
villain keys college. This
provided him with a secure job,
which gave him further
confidence in his future. Yes,
his condition had now reached the
stage where he could no longer. Right.
So he had to rely on Jane
to record his thoughts.
Hawkings job at the college required him
to supervise students for a few hours
every day, providing him with plenty
of time to pursue his research studies.
He and Jane set up that home and a
small house not far from the college.
They enjoyed entertaining friends and
the house was often filled with dinner
guests.
In December of 1965 hawking was invited
to the United States to give an address
or to Miami conference.
However,
his speech was so slurred that a friend
had to read the address on his behalf.
The speech,
though it was well received.
Further cementing is growing reputation
as an exciting new thinker in the world
of cosmology. Mom Jane spends a lot of
time and effort caring for her husbands.
She had given up on our own career
when the couple have had maths.
She was in the midst of a
degree in modern languages.
She completed that
degree in 1967 that year.
She also gave birth to their first child.
Robert.
Two more children would follow Blue Lucy
in 1970 and Timothy in 1979 the birth
of his first child was a
further motivated for Hawkings.
He look positively toward
the future despite the fact
that he's already outlived
his initial prognosis.
He had a family now along with a promising
career is a budding genius. In fact,
some were even already calling
him the success at Einstein.
Yeah,
the turning points in Hawking's Korea.
Cause when he attended a lecture by
mathematician Robert Penn rose in the
address,
Penrose expounded his theory of space
time singularity in the center of a black
hole. Okay. Latched on to the pen,
raised singularity theory and
applied it to the entire universe.
If he could prove the
mathematics behind it,
he knew that this would
be a momentous addition.
Do you the understanding of the origins
of the universe mathematics was hawking
strong points.
So he collaborated with
Penrose who presented his
calculations by way of visual
representations in order to help
hawking who was unable to recall the
calculations himself.
The Big Bang theory was predicated on the
idea that the universe was not static,
but actually it continually expanding.
According to this theory,
the universe began as a black hole.
It was held together by gravity,
Viagra at the center of the holy.
It was extremely hot and does it
cooled over billions of years.
It started to expand with the protons,
neutrons and electrons forming the
stars and the galaxies which make up our
visible universe. Hawking. He was not
the originator of this new theory,
but his work such as the
essay singularities and the
geometry of space time gave
it a strong underpinning.
By the ends of the 1960s Hawking's,
als had deteriorated to the point
where he had become wheelchair bound.
The intense speed of his mental cognition,
however,
caused him to move around with
maximum speed in its we'll chat.
It also caused him to quickly become
impatient and irritable with those around
him.
Despite his raw temperaments,
IEM actually became very popular with
students and colleagues alike and the
early 1970s hogging took on the task of
reconciling the two opposing theories
that had divided physics for years.
Quantum mechanics and relativity.
During his work,
he discovered that black holes in it,
radiation.
He published this finding in
an article in nature magazine.
There was initially
some push back to this,
but eventually his finding was accepted.
Then that came to be known
as hawking radiation.
The discovery of black hole radiation
was a big deal and it led to publicity
beyond the scientific community.
Working with now receiving general
media attention giving rise to the fame,
which would see him lauded
as the wheelchair genius.
In 1973 hawking published his first book,
the large scale structure of space time.
The following year or read 32 he became
one of the youngest people to become a
member of the Royal Society
in 1974 B with salsa.
We invited to spend a year at the
California Institute of Technology. Yeah.
He was able to make use of
the very best equipment,
including the jet propulsion laboratory
that is attached to the institute during
his year in America.
He was able to work alongside
famous American theoretical
physicist, kept thorn.
The Hawkins family thoroughly enjoyed
their year in Sunny California.
Over the years.
Steven would frequently return to
Caltech to make you sit there advanced
facilities. At the end of that time in
the u s the family returned to Cambridge.
Where have they moved into a bigger
house on the college grounds.
In 1976 the students in residents by
the name of Don page joins the hawking
households.
Paige would walk walking to this
office every morning and perform other
caretaking jobs.
Around this time,
Jane began to feel confined by her life
as a mother and a wife to a wheel chair,
bound husbands with page now on hand
to help out with Steven's Kashi embarks
upon a phd in medieval Spanish poetry.
Once she gained did,
she began teaching at
Cambridge University.
The couple began experiencing marital
problems from the mid 1970s one cause of
their discord was the wildly divergent
religious views that each health Jane was
a committed Christian welp Steven.
He was a confirmed atheist.
The relationship remained strained until
the divorce in 1995 in 1976 or hawking
was invited to a number of conferences
around the United States following which
he ended up on TV. Talk shows though
his speech was difficult to understand.
He did prove hips with American audiences.
In 1979 hawking was appointed Lucchese
and professor of mathematics at Cambridge.
This position brought great prestige with
the couple now being the center of the
Cambridge social elite.
Hawking enjoyed attending concerts
and movies and despite his physical
limitations, he was enjoying his
life more than ever before. Still,
he became disappointed at the back of
facilities for handicapped people in the
community and became an advocate
for disabled facilities.
In 1983 a BBC horizon documentary gave
TV viewers and insight into the private
life of the wheelchair genius.
This went a long way in
promoting his celebrity status.
In 1984 he put out several feelers to
publishing houses to write a definitive
book of his theories for a lay audience.
Bantam publishing offered him a
$250,000 advance. It took four years.
Do you produce the book,
which is called a brief history of time.
It became an instant best seller and
to date has sold more than 10 million
copies.
In July of 1985 hawking was in Geneva
when he found himself unable to breathe.
After arriving in the hospital,
he underwent tracheotomy
surgery. The surgery.
It was a success,
but the payoff was that he lost his voice.
The challenge was now how to provide
hawking with a way to communicate with the
world, and this was solved by a
computer programmer by the name of Walt.
Walt halls has equalizer program allowed
hawking to select words from a screen
that would then be converted
into a voice synthesizer
from the early 1980s onwards or walking
had employed fulltime nurses by the end
of the decade. He had become
alarmingly close to one of them.
A woman by the name of Alain Mason.
She was a woman with a dominant since
protective personality in early 1990
hawking told Jane that he was leaving
the family home and moving in with Elaine
Mason with herself,
married to a family friend at that time,
Hawking Institute of divorce proceedings
to officially end his marriage to Jane.
When the divorce came through in 1995 he
and Elaine were married in the ensuing
years that were rumors that Elaine was
physically controlling and abusive to her
husband's. After 11 years, the
marriage ended in autobiography.
Hawking referred to you his years with
Elaine as passionate and tempestuous.
In the 1990s hawking became
interested in time travel.
He was of the opinion that
the only possible way for
time travel to exist would
be if it did not alter the status quo.
In other words,
if a time travel machine could
be created in the future,
people would only be able to travel back
until the time when that machine was
created because prior to that time,
the machine did not exist. Many people,
they rejected Hawkings ideas on time
travel and in order to prove his point in
an irreverent way,
he decided to hold a party,
which was I even do anyone and
serve free food and champagne.
The catch was that he only advertise
the events after it had occurred.
So only time travelers
would be aware of it. Um,
surprisingly though no one turns up and
the early two thousands hawking focused
on publishing more popular books starting
with 2000 and one's the universe in a
nutshell. And in 2005 he put
out a brief history of time,
both of which were best sellers
by then his iconic status.
It was well established to being cemented
with appearances on the Simpsons and
star Trek.
The next generation.
By 2005 Hawkings condition
had deteriorated to the
extent that he could only
control his speech controls with
movements of his cheek muscles.
From 2009 he could no longer move his
electric wheelchair himself and his
breathing became increasingly difficult.
The end came peacefully on the morning
of March the 14th 2018 it was the 139th
anniversary of the birth
of Albert Einstein.
The Stephen Hawking was a professor at
one of the best universities in the world
since he was a man who
shared his knowledge with
the world through books that
can be understood by everyday folks and
that's why I'm particularly pleased that
the great courses plus is involved with
today's video on their learning platform.
You can learn from Ivy League professors
and others as they give lectures online.
These can be a great way to learn about
some of the concepts that hawking works
on, infusing lectures about
black holes and quantum physics,
but there's also plenty of other stuff
on there from history to travel to help.
Basically it's really
a university education,
but it's at your own pace with no tests
and no schedules and it's also very easy
to access. You can do it on your PC,
on your tablet, even on your phone.
They've even recently added streaming
so you can listen on the move.
Something I particularly love,
I just pop the audio in when I'm
walking around or going for a jog.
And on the platform there are currently
10,000 lectures that you can choose from.
So yeah,
it's all great stuff and the best way
to find that out is to try for yourself.
And you can do that for free by going
to the great courses plus.com forward
slash biographics or simply clicking
the link in the description below.
And doing that does help support this
show getting more biographics out to you
every week. So again,
the great courses plus,
it's just a great way to expand your
knowledge on a whole range of subjects
taught by the in the wells. And as always,
I really hope you enjoyed the video.
Please do give it a thumbs up if you
didn't. Don't forget to subscribe.
Also hit that bell button when
you click the subscribe button,
because subscribed doesn't
really do anything anymore.
So if you actually want to find
out when we put out new videos,
you've got to hit that bell. It's
just the way it goes. And as always,
thank you for watching.